[Música]
bond a culpa
bom dia vocês sabem o que é consciência
financeira
será que crianças podem nem deve pensar
nesse assunto
vamos falar sobre o que você faria se
você ganhasse 20 reais por semana você
gastaria tudo de uma vez só gastaria
pouco foi pouco
pense bem bom é que eu vou dar alguns
exemplos de coisas que muita gente acha
dinheiro necessariamente como islaine já
tem material para fazer eu não vou
precisar comprar mais debates é aquela
coisa só porque natal na modinha e todo
mundo vai usar não significa que vou
encontrar primeiro que eu não sou todo
mundo segundo que se eu já tenho o meu
eu não preciso maquiagem acaba de lançar
uma marca nova que eu nunca usei na
minha vida mas já tenho as minhas
é necessário comprar só quando precisar
doses na cantina e aquele docinho
irresistível que ninguém aguenta
eu estou eu não estou mais com fome já
lanchei mas eu olho para a vitrine de
repente eu vejo um docinho que eu não me
que eu não resista
ai que vontade mas aí eu pensei melhor e
acho que é melhor deixar para depois
assim o gasto meu dinheiro se você
decidir gastar seu dinheiro de uma vez
só
você vai acabar ficando sem dinheiro que
se ninguém quer você precisa se planejar
de forma mais consciente e financeira
assim você vai ter dinheiro pra tudo que
você necessite necessitar
minha ideia é um ep que vai ajudar as
crianças a guardarem melhor o seu
dinheirinho e os pais a criança não
poder ter acesso é ciep ajudando elas a
ter mais responsabilidade e guardar um
dinheirinho para o seu projeto futuro
os pais vão poder acompanhar onde é que
essa gastou e quanto ela gastou aqui
está um esboço do epp que eu fiz que ele
vai chamar que as financeiras
aqui eu tenho alguns passes para você
conseguir entrar no mar
cadé se no ep mas são os seus projetos
futuros com valor
adicione quanto dinheiro você ganha
escolhe a câmera se planejar e adicione
com que você mais gosta
vamos começar a prática muito obrigada
pela atenção
[Aplausos]
[Música]